ladies and gentlemen the great honking
is winning
we're learning now that quebec is
pulling its tax on the unvacs out of a
fear of social cohesion breaking down
we've got other reports that mounties i
think mountains right rcmp those are the
mounties right they were threatening to
arrest the truckers and they backed down
so this may be a victory in some
respects but the war is still raging and
the great honking continues and here in
the u.s there is more and more talk
about american truckers getting on board
with their own kind of great a freedom
convoy or great honking
so we have much to talk about we'll talk
about all that plus more we've got a
story about jack pasovek being smeared
by the media and jack's actually here
but first let's uh let's throw it to uh
lily tang williams is joining us do you
want to introduce yourself
yes lady tang williams i'm gonna put
your mic up sorry oh okay is that better
no pull pull it closer to you well close
to me yeah
there you go
yes chinese immigrant
americans by choice running for u.s
congress in the great state of new
hampshire free state project yes and uh
um
thanks for having me happy new year
everybody today is the first day of
chinese tiger year so where is this
jackie for you guys you've actually
experienced lovely the awfulness of
communism
yeah yes i lived in china
for almost 24 years
to me it's like a
i was not free i wasn't a slave so i
feel very young in this country because
i started
my new life free person life as 24 years
old so i'm i i think it'll be great to
talk to you about what we're seeing with
the vaccine mandates and all those
policies what your experience was in
under chinese the chinese communist
party i think there's probably some
similarities that imagine of course
quite a lot that's why i'm on ronnie i'm
terrified right on all right we'll talk
about it we got jack besovic here as
well
they're making fun of you
so tim whenever we speak chinese it's
not good for you
so
my hair for chinese kids whenever their
friends come over if i start speak to
them in chinese they know they're from
uh what they call the tiger mom
yeah exactly is that it but you ever
know
the tiger right oh it's that you're the
tigers we got tiger mom in the or the
tiger
now yeah yeah so i think everybody knows
who jack is but you know just you know
yeah jack pasobic uh he was a host of
human events daily also the senior
editor over there uh i'm host on the
turning point live network as well as a
million different things now published
in newsweek which of course is made uh
nbc's resident medhi hassan very upset
because i was going after nbc and their
relationship with the ccp and many
others and their relationships with the
ccp so of course he comes out to try to
smear me try to cancel me and is
incredibly impotent it's amazing in fact
you know newsweek does a pretty good job
i'm impressed they have an eclectic set
of opinions in their opinion well so
they're running dissenting views now and
so they'll actually set it up
they weren't able to do it because of
you know sometimes they can get the
timing right they'll actually pick
someone on the left and someone on the
right and so if you go to their opinion
page it'll say you know sort of like
this person on the left versus this
person on the right and maybe the topic
is vaccine mandates or the topic is the
new voting rights project or you know
biden's voting right whatever it is
right and they'll run opposing views
which is something that newspapers and
magazines used to do in the past all the
time and yet somehow you know later on
into the 2000s we split into oh no this
side is only going to give one opinion
this one's only going to give another so
um everything that josh hammer and
uh they're mad about the whole team is
doing over there is is amazing because
yeah and you've got mediason and people
like this saying no you can't run these
people because they have bad opinions
and very naughty thoughts yo we uh we're
winning free speech free own free
inquiry free association it's all
winning so
exactly what joe rogan said too by the
way recently so welcome and uh
unfortunately my friends ian is not here
instead we have sheamus stole his spot
so these are the credentials i have to
follow up i make cartoons
i have a youtube channel
thank you lily i appreciate that someone
here has my back we have one fan um so i
have youtube channel called freedom
tunes where we create educational
cartoons and mostly political satire at
this point started more educational but
some educational stuff too if you guys
want to check that out we release a new
video every thursday and i'm really
excited for tonight's show i think we're
gonna have a great taught myself
investing just by watching freedom tunes
yeah exactly that's true that's not true
but you can
you could you you actually invest in
freedom tunes
totally set them up for them you know
what the company's country do to
cartoonists and communities
[Music]
we also got lydia pressing the buttons i
am here in the corner i get the
impression i'm not going to be talking a
lot tonight but i'm very excited for
tonight's conversation can't wait to
learn more about canada and china all
right everybody before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
to help support our work support our
fierce and independent journalists and
as a member you'll get access to
exclusive segments from the tim cast irl
podcast uncensored just for you guys
that is over at timcast.com but don't
forget one like equals one honk so honk
the like button
support the pumpkin honk
we gotta get a goose honk buddy
for the honking and uh share this video
uh share the story with your friends if
you like the show and again timcast.com
subscribe to the channel yadda yadda
let's talk about this this story right
here we got this from timcast.com quebec
pulls proposed tax on unvaccinated
canadians premier francois gold cited
today cited a desire to maintain social
cohesion in his announcement on february
1st i have to wonder what that might
mean i mean that's incredible it means
become ungovernable exactly well this is
sort of what we were talking about the
other day when i was saying a huge
reason this trucker convoy is a threat
to them is because peop people realize
they can stand up for themselves and
don't have to obey every order they're
not going to be as effective when they
try i mean like people have power or
yeah exactly what does that mean people
have all the power whoa whoa
you mean like workers of the world are
united
no no not like that right right right i
think it's funny that i've pointed out
you know we've talked about
there's like a meme about whenever
workers actually do start protesting but
it's for like the wrong direction the
left gets mad about it and it's never
been exemplified better than it is now
with truckers workers of the world
uniting in opposition to government
authoritarianism and now they're all
getting angry about it but but but the
point is
the point of this story is
to maintain social cohesion yeah it's
working it's it's it's having an impact
when people stand together and push back
and honk their horns
the powers that be recoil and fear i
mean i just love seeing these these
comments where you know so it's it's
like somebody's screaming i just can't
take it anywhere you know these attract
these racist whites and families here
they're in there in the downtown and
whatever they're and then you just and
the response is just honk
honk yeah you know this reminds me in
china when they took this app off young
people's phone
to have like a basically funny stuff and
talk about their private you know sex
and dating
and the government even banned that app
and how did they protest it to find our
own people they go out and
dd diddy they pushed their car diddy
really is like hey friend hey hey
comrade diddy diddy uh because dd was
the name of the app right
no it was like
the car noise did you also use the app
right the name of the app was dd yeah
right they thought yeah they did it was
like so they were marking the horns to
make it sound like dd it sounds like
indeed
against
the government who took away people's
entertainment so that's that tells you
the state of today's young people in
china they're just they have no meanings
in life
i don't i don't know if it was you
posted it jack someone posted george
soros getting angry about what china was
doing and speaking out against him was
it wasn't you tweeted about that uh brie
dale had tweeted it and then i i'd
commented someone said that soros is
finally realizing yeah that was me yeah
the west is going to be subservient to
china in this you know after this great
reset or whatever right so and you're
seeing this like jake taper at cnn is
now attacking china during the olympics
and george soros was out and come out
and put this video and so people are
saying hey wait what's going on like why
you know why why is soros the guy who's
mr open society mr color revolution you
know who's spread so much misinformation
actual discord means the guy funded all
these crazy da's across the united
states that lets violent criminals out
on the streets and that's why homicides
are to complete um record highs across
the country but suddenly he's against
the ccp what's this and i said you get
like no guys this is game of thrones
stuff right this is stuff that's going
on at the higher level it's who gets to
be senior partner who get to be junior
partner and the idea was the west
thought they were going to be the senior
partners but suddenly they realize that
if all the manufacturing is in another
country then guess what
that country's the one with the power
you know i almost can't believe that's
the reason because how stupid do you
have to be
for you know for for these these these
industrialists these wealthy individuals
these global leaders to outright be like
no no it's fine if we move our
manufacturing to china it's a good thing
and now they hold all the cards and
they're like uh okay maybe that was a
bad thing do you remember when
republicans when so trump used to talk
about this and this was one of the
singular issues i think two of his
biggest issues immigration and china
right we're like two of the absolute
biggest ones and both of them revolve
around the concept of sovereignty but on
those focused issues he really changed
the conversation on and i remember when
he started coming out and saying
we need to have steel tariffs because
the steel industry is a matter of
national security in the united states
there were so many of these like
libertarian type conservatarian
republicans say what do you mean what
what does that have to do with national
security that's just that's just the
steel industry and we should have uh you
know the free flow of capital and goods
and people across borders and the free
you know free trade is really what
matters and he turns around and said
yeah well what if we get into a war with
china and we can't make steel to build
equipment for our military what if uh
there's a global pandemic and we can't
make vitamin c oops or antibiotics right
right that's why it's more than national
security it's a matter of knife and
death if you rely on them
so now you say they had the ppe mask
diplomacy right and they use that and
now you know next don't know what they
use and now they're probably everybody
so
you literally you actually lived under
the you know communism in in china now
i'm curious uh since we've last had you
on there's been a lot of developments
with the vaccine mandates and all that
stuff i'm curious what your thoughts are
on all of it and the similarities
well i'm so encouraged by this uh
truckers freedom convoy that's like i
have never seen canadians
are so excited about their country we
saw canadian socialist country i have
been telling people the vaccine passport
have a qr code on your cell phone
it would be just like china's
social credit system they'll track you
long stop 24 hours a day wow you'll have
no prices private well i haven't seen
this one guy showed me in las vegas he's
a qr code on his cell phone from saudi
arabia he said lily i have to have three
shots in order to travel to las vegas
for business i said well how how do you
show them the papers i show you he
showed me his qr code on his cell phone
i said that looks like china's cell
phone social current assistant you have
been tracked 24 hours a day he said what
choice do i have so i'm telling people
in this country with some word if you
let them to do that
it's under view basic human freedom it's
it's black mirror it's how have we made
a tv show about this and now we're it's
not even been a couple of years and
we're already enacting it yes exactly i
have uh uh friends of friends stories
i've heard about people who are
currently traveling around in china and
it's like oh yeah you have to scan
everything to get in any everywhere
you've got you got to be completely up
to date and then to get into any
building it's scanned and all tracked
everywhere you go well for
um for beijing olympics which are coming
down they're locking down so they have
to be very careful about this because
they don't want to lock down beijing
itself and so the olympic star what in
two two or three days i think and three
days and
they're locking down various districts
of beijing but they're not actually
locking down the main centers yet now
they have this thing called the bubble
or if you're in they call it being in
the loop when you come in but they're
even with because they're uh pursuing
the zero covet strategy even with that
they've had breakthrough cases inside
that bubble so what are they doing if
you're anywhere near there if a single
case comes out they will lock you down
inside a shopping mall they're locking
down entire office buildings so for how
long
until everyone tests negative
so zero
so you're trapped in a mall for like two
weeks so whatever it is wow you're just
locked in there i'm not surprised they
were welding people's doors precisely
yeah i don't know why ilc would not
delay it or changing location and they
also change the human rights rules that
they want to apply to you know paris to
other places but not to beijing there's
a lot of questions needed to be raised
what is iowa is doing in beijing now
with all that strict zero covey
lockdowns well are the athletes gonna
protest it and bail out or right or are
they just gonna go along with it i
haven't seen any athletes protesting it
because i and i remember too like go
back and look at um the rio olympics
which were just a couple of years ago
and when zika virus was going on and i
remember olymp you know a lot of
athletes saying hey i'm not going to go
to rio because i don't want zika right
well we're seeing the exact same thing
with the omicron olympics but to answer
your question what's up with the ioc i
mean it's pretty simple and this is what
i actually wrote about in newsweek and
nbc's get you know sending out this this
uh hitman to come after me um is that
you're i've heard people describe their
relationship with something like elite
capture like the ccp has captured
american elites but it's not like that
it's actually elite merger that's what
we're seeing across the world and so yes
there's this argument over who gets to
be senior partner and who gets to be
junior partner but at the end of the day
this has been a merger that's been in
place for almost 30 years now certainly
with since their ascension to the wto
and that's why when you see these things
like hunter biden's laptop or the fact
that barbara boxer the former senator
from california is now a registered
agent of a ccp surveillance company
which actually makes the cameras for
xinjiang right i mean you could go look
all this stuff up but can you say it
like alex jones now
oh right right well you see uh i got
over the years they're 30 years they've
been sending us up they've been selling
us out they've been sitting there
they're sitting out selling out your
children they're gonna be hooked up to
the ccp machines
it's funny because when you talk about
uh you know you have what is that
picture of klaus schwab holding the
great reset book or something right the
media told us it's a conspiracy theory
there's no great reset and he's like
smiling with us but he wrote the book
it's just so insane how
the i got to say it it does feel like
we're winning when you get stories like
the truckers pushing back them starting
to back down it they
they couldn't pull off what they thought
they could pull off
what i mean by that they i mean like
these authoritarian political
establishment elite types but you know
it'll come next right just you just wait
give it this like a couple of more days
of the trucker protests and you're
immediately going to see the media flood
the zone mark my word screenshot this
whatever i know we're live um
you will see the media
pushing stories about self-driving
trucks very very soon
as a response to all of this yeah
suddenly and like i'm because yang
talked about this a lot and you're gonna
say oh no it'll be so great and they
won't get an accident and time will you
know the people will travel faster
because they don't have the time
restrictions that truckers have etcetera
that's the next thing that's coming
guaranteed let me pull up the story we
got from the daily mail police threaten
to arrest truckers blockading the us
border in alberta unless they leave cops
give freedom convoy and ultimatum after
their one-time cheerleader justin
trudeau turned on them for protesting
his vaccine mandates so
ultimately
the the rcmp backed down but is this
them saying well you know them the
mounties are leaving because we've
issued your warning we'll come back
later or are they completely unable to
do anything about these trucks i mean
that's kind of the thing right and and
hats off to rebel news um i think the
website is convoy reports.com they have
up i think they have they're doing a
fundraiser for lawyers by the way so
what we're talking about for people who
um that aren't familiar you have
truckers right now that are on the
border
between alberta and montana that are
actually blocking the maid roadway on
this and i pulled it up on the map this
is your basically
your main border crossing between
calgary and the entire pacific northwest
so if you're coming out of that main
city of uh central and this is a central
agricultural hub this is a cattle hub so
your beef
some poultry that's all coming out of
there out of calgary out of that area
they're locking it all down now the
truckers are just basically standing
there saying look this is a standoff we
are not cut we are not going to move the
mounties and rebel rebel news as far as
i can tell are the only ones that
actually have people who are embedded
there because there's no way to get
there right now otherwise so it's like
the middle of nowhere but they're
putting up and i'm looking just a couple
of minutes ago
um the alberta premiere kenny just
declared that the blockade is unlawful
warning the participants are subject to
arrest and they're broadcasting so this
is like kind of like
it's not like this but it's similar to
the bundy ranch standoff that took place
or the mulher um reservation it's not
like that in the sense they haven't
taken over you know like a federal
facility or anything like that but this
time around rebel media is actually in
there embedded so they've just six
minutes ago posted a video of of the
truckers releasing a statement in
response to the alberta premiere saying
look we want dialogue we want
communication and we want the mandates
this is a lot like occupy wall street
it's so much like occupation yeah you've
got uh you're mentioning earlier that
viva fry was on the ground for like six
hours six hours he didn't do 21 like i
did but he's a cool guy
we're we're fantastic
it's no big deal but no no but he was
you were saying that you know he's going
around live streaming on the ground and
you know embedded in this moment
very similar to what happened with
occupy wall street not just with like me
covering this and people were giving him
batteries people were like coming up to
him recognizing him and saying oh viva
yeah i need battery pacman and they
would give him a pack and then he went
into an office at one point and was
charging his phone but like interviewing
someone while he charged his phone i
mean it's crazy he was like meeting you
know uh
and there was like a singer songwriter
this girl who was there and she like
played amazing grace just for him and
he's talking to truckers and retired
people it was i honestly i kid you not i
was watching his live streams and then
just any live stream i could of these
trucker protests for like the last three
days straight so if you've been in my
house or if you've been at the studio a
town in dc literally you see me at the
computer all you hear in the background
is just
hong kong
and i love it with every hunk it just
gets better and better i want i need to
like louder and louder yes more honking
absolutely so see that's the big
difference if you are citizen journalist
you are in china on the ground reporting
live stream from the kobe side
you disappear very fast
you know 10 years oh yeah
all those citizen journalists they're
locked up we don't know where they are
they could be dying of some disease or
something you don't know
if there's a big difference that's why
it's so important for people who love
freedom to appreciate what they have now
you got to fight so hard to keep it you
know yep if i could ask you lily what is
one thing that you think americans need
to band together and do right now to
prevent our country from becoming like
the one you left
well that that's why i'm running for u.s
congress right because i said why i'm
running because i fear the country i
love is becoming like the country i
loved
and it's getting worse and worse not two
years i could not sleep i saw the
writings on the wall
and i saw the similar tactics and
features what's going on in this country
with the mouse cultural revolution i
survived
i just feel like it's like when you see
your neighbor's house on fire they don't
know
what should i do i see it i gotta warn
them right hey your house isn't on fire
so our country is going down that path
very fast i have to do something about
it and the last americans when i go out
to speak about my stories they're all
very interested in listening to me but
it's like how come they did not listen
to some stories learn hershey about it
before so
look into our educational system yeah so
are you are you running uh for the
libertarian party or i'm running as a
republican oh republican yes i'm uh i
have around as before in colorado
um
lp has no valley access and the
republican party in new hampshire is
quite good there are lots of people like
me inside to make things happening like
like lots of doing state house in state
senate were passing some very good laws
right now and where it passed whole
bunch last year that are now democrats
trying to reverse them they they're
trying to sue our state now
to
forbidden schools to teach
discrimination
when race is more superior or interfered
than others what's wrong with that it's
in our state constitution you cannot
teach discrimination in schools but this
will we cannot teach history anymore we
are so afraid of discussions of slavery
which is not true yeah i i i see the
memes all day and night so my facebook
is comprised of
populists across the board i mean occupy
wall street's a big populist movement
and it's split in a lot of ways a lot of
people who supported occupy ended up
supporting trump later on many have went
for bernie so it's surprising when i see
the divide
and it really is a stark contrast
what i see from the left outright says
the right has stepped up to banning
books on slavery they're overtly racist
and white supremacist and like that's
just fundamentally not true it's a lie
they're pushing that lie about the book
mouse total lie total lie so they're
saying the book has been banned if
you're if your book is available on the
rack at barnes noble it's not banned
well if you can bring it into the school
and you can read it it's not banned
right so
the story is essentially that they voted
to remove from the curriculum it's like
okay there's a lot of books that aren't
in school curriculum they're not all
banned imagine if they were like you
know we have 500 books in the curriculum
that means 10 billion books are banned
that's insane but with the narrative
that's coming out is oh no they're
banning books they're banning books and
there's nothing you can say to change
any of their minds because there is a
tribal narrative another thing i want to
say
that i testified in state capital
because the teachers union supporters
want to reverse our laws right and they
are suing our state and you got about 20
people showed up to testify support that
re um like a bill and you got the two an
agent you know women who fled communism
to give our strong two cents there were
totally outnumbered two to twenty but we
went there without the paper in front of
us we just told our stories and i called
the nea i said well if you look at nea
national the largest union national
website they said clearly budget to
teach
critical register into 14 000 school
districts but the people say oh we're
not teaching critical research schools
really i said welcome you new hampshire
chapter of nea to come out make public
statement about that because i said if
on teach real history i'm living history
i would like to go to your school teach
your kids about communities how about
that yeah let's do it yeah yeah so they
should so you're uh
you're running for uh for the republican
uh uh nomination
yes there are five there are five
republican man in the primary with me
and i welcome all good men but i have a
compelling unique story
and i understand how precious our
freedom is
i feel confident with the grassroots
support hey everybody is watching please
lillytownwithnames.com 10
and i can win i can be frontrunner
tonight you can make me frown under
tonight in the republican primary
to say hey we love lily she's
representing the common people and she
is a fierce freedom fighter why not let
her are you are you uh
are you involved in the free state
project
um i moved there and signed a pledge to
make maximum
efforts to create a free society i was
attacked for that by the left when i was
running for little tongue supervisor of
the checklist
because it's non-partisan race but when
they find out i was a free stater they
come attack me
and like it's like why i'm sh shouldn't
they be for freedom
for your diet so that's so important
but whether they granted progressives
come out organize workshops in the
libraries every election year to tell
people
who are they free staters we are the
radical
and right when nuts something like that
they're saying so they even don't
understand how organizations work
everybody goes there and once they sign
a pledge you move there you do whatever
you want it's up to you there's no dues
there's no requirement you're on your
own and i choose my own course you know
so uh so you're running for for federal
congress right
yes and if i a nomination i will be the
historically first chinese immigrant
from maine and china who survived
communism to be nominee of a republican
party in the country and then uh when
you get to washington will you uh
do everything in your efforts to repeal
unconstitutional gun bans
you know and things like that of course
if you have nothing right
if you have not seen my junk stocks or
interview
i was holding
my ar-15
i love it in front of us flat i was
attacked also by some local left people
to say she looked very scary they're
losers she's holding ar-15 i said well
i am a survivor of communism i believe
second amendment right otherwise all
those students in tiananmen square will
not be killed without a fight right
that's right and you tell me that i look
scary i'm a five foot one a chinese
woman and i'm very intimidating you know
so they're afraid of guns basically so i
think that's part of the problem people
are afraid of guns have they tried to
handle guns in children range when i
first came to united states first time
touch gun i was scared too so i don't
know what to do i was like oh oh people
say oh no no don't put my people lady
number one rule
yes
you should teach alec baldwin
i scared all my you know husband this
family is like oh god forgot you're from
china you never touch guns i feel so
empowered when i first time hold the guy
in my hands very first shot yeah it's
like wow because i never
had that feeling i was deprived of gun
ownership 1.4 billion chinese today
deprived
the self-defense right
that's why they are quiet that's why
they comply no matter how bad their life
become you know what can you do you know
people don't realize about the second
amendment the left often says what are
you gonna do rise up against the
government blah blah no that's not what
it's about it's for one it's it's a it's
a force it's a force balancer so you
mentioned tiananmen square
they roll out these tanks right so so
and then basically you tell me exactly
what happened with tiananmen square they
came and they killed all these students
so what happens that uh um one the
um premier of china huyabang he was the
one not just advocate for economical
freedom he was talking about we should
have political freedom as well so we
were in college and like
let's talk about let's have a
conversation what kind of country we
want can we become a western democracy
countries people can vote can have a
dialogue with our leaders so they were
peaceful and but when this leader died
and they were actually just going to
tiananmen square to mourn his death lots
lots of you know those chinese you know
and flowers and all that but then
after a couple weeks and people start to
say hey we want to have dialogue with
our leaders they were not calling to
overthrow the government no they just
say can we have a dialogue can we be
represented can we have a continued
dialogue about political freedom like a
right to vote and right to appeal rule
of law
and at the beginning and the government
will quiet and then more and more
students show up and more and more
students starting other cities of the
province like capitals like my hometown
and um even when guava chopper visited
china that time by the time it was like
400 000 students yemen square and they
had to reroute for him to visit the
state so after that i heard that the
xiaoping when back then was the leader
and talked to the military in beijing to
say and go rowing to the champions
square but the beijing troops knew
those were our best and brightest
students and peaceful they were not
going to kill them and you see citizens
come up bake them to leave and literally
have offered them water and bread to
when they're hungry to say leave you
know they're not threats they're not
country revolutionaries go home so
beijing general actually later got fired
because beijing troops left wow that in
xiaoping went back to hubei where wuhan
is capital to say
go to tiermann square a whole bunch of
young people county revolutionary are
trying to overthrow the government
traders traders basically they kill them
all
ten thousand estimated to be to die then
so what people need to understand about
the second amendment
that that story what would what what
would have happened if they actually
were armed i don't think it would have
escalated to a major conflict it would
have escalated to a dialogue because the
government would be like look we're not
going to go in there people there have
have weapons and we don't it could go it
could go south real quick so we need to
figure out how to defuse this in the
united states a lot of these you know
large instances these large moments
where people the left is like what do
you think you're going to do rise up
against the government blah blah blah no
it just never escalates that point
because no one they they know that
there's a mutually assured destruction
but a really good example of the
deterring effect and the the bouncing uh
the force balancer is the brianna taylor
story the police kicked the door in
briana taylor's boyfriend returned fire
hitting a cop with a bullet the cop was
bleeding from the leg they fired they
killed brianna taylor
but there were no the charges were
dropped against the boyfriend because he
had a right to keep and bear arms and
defend his home that means the police in
this country know
a law-abiding citizen may be armed and
if you try and break into their house
and violate their rights you could die
you could die and and the per and
grandchild's boyfriend did not get in
trouble i mean they they they pushed him
through it a little bit but eventually
he just was like look it was it was it
was a lawful self-defense of his house
so in a country like you look at these
videos out of australia or the uk the
cops kick the door and they walk and
they do whatever they want in the united
states
not so much still yes they do but not so
much well that's why um if you look at
my past 2013 i published open ad by
national review online to say like a
guns against tyranny
and i talk about yemen square i talk
about chinese people feel powerless to
defend themselves their families and
anybody can kick your door open
and
we i was told when i leave a very poor
in military working parents neighborhood
say hey if criminals come go grab our
choppers in the kitchen like when you
like do bones and chickens you know your
souls
chopsticks don't do any sense so you
have to just grab the knives you know so
when i come to this country when i first
time got
passionately involved in politics
because 2013 the democrats in colorado
wanted to limit the ar-15 magazines so i
testified first time i did not know how
to testify in this long line i had to go
in with somebody my smart
rat is like like my husband called me
straight red i survived china so i said
i'm not going to get it in there testify
they're lying so long be midnight but i
saw somebody's expert witness like a
president of rocky mountain governor
association say
hey
can i go in with you because i survived
china i want to give my two cents he
said okay come with me so i went in with
him first time i testify in my life in
my new country to say what you're doing
is the communist way i we need to have a
second mind to the right to defend
ourselves is our god-given right are you
becoming like a communist well nobody
said anything but they passed the bill
along the party tonight i become
political activists after that what's
good for you
yes let's turn my mouse chairman mao is
the one who said this perfectly
political power grows from the barrel of
a gun
and then what did the ccp do
they banned all the guns well when the
prc fund in 1949 my dad told me he
remembered because before that some
people still have some guns even though
nationalist party by shanghai she also
started to have gun control north
because you know he was kind of corrupt
too but after prc they commonly said
turn over all your guns whatever you
have in your house include those people
who were supposed to be kind of like a
little bit like a malaysia group turn
your guns oh we searched door by door
then you go to jail you will find a gun
in your house i love this point um i
hate that i'm able to make it when these
you know democrat types say no one is
trying to take your guns away i just say
waco
and then they'll if they don't know what
it is i'll be like how many children are
worth killing so that you can take guns
ruby rich yeah you know there are lots
of cases to prove and the people
unless some people will say i guarantee
you one hundred percent that our
government in the u.s will not become
tyrants
who can guarantee that if you don't
trust that then
gang debate is over it's it's simple
over a long enough period of time a
system that has centralized authority
you if you have a hundred leaders
and you have a system of centralized
authority and 99 of them are good people
but you end up finally getting that one
dictator then he goes nuts and and
seizes more power and kills people it's
we just shouldn't have that centralized
kind of power just like a mall right
most like social past so you don't have
a rule of law you have a rule of man
what if you run into seven mad man and
when i was growing up as one madman
sociopath 20 million people died during
his cultural revolution so so you go
through the cultural revolution in china
you come to the u.s you're in colorado
and you said 2013 i think right
and now
how do you i mean i kind of asked you
this already but seeing everything
that's going on right now it's got to be
kind of like
nerve-wracking you're like i i left
trying to get away from this and now
these countries are doing similar things
and they're ramping up towards this this
you know authoritarianism well that uh
um like the defectors from russia they
said that too see the you know they will
corrupt the free world one little bit
socialism
and every day so they sell you free
stuff first so our young people need to
realize that free stuff it's what they
use to get you an interesting and
socialism because every equity i mean
they don't realize that is a company's
term so once you get into the door you
vote for them and they have total
control oh all of a sudden you cannot
vote anymore yeah you cannot have guns
anymore you cannot have a private
property anymore and your children don't
belong to you they belong to the state
and you don't have a medical decision
anymore you know we have seen plenty of
that in the past two years that's why i
feel like i can do more now by going to
wrong
for office so i can't get my messages up
i want to pull up this tweet here
from benny johnson
savage canadian conservative leader puts
final nail in trudeau's coffin in
parliament in front of the whole world
this is a truly epic 30 second smackdown
and the reason i think this clip is
important is that it shows for all of
the bad that's been happening in uh in
the in western countries there there is
still an active resistance speaking up
and saying no
listen to this this is in relation to
the trucker's protest the freedom convoy
the great honking and how trudeau and
kendall lied smearing these people
listen to this
let me actually fix the audio canadians
i do get very defensive of canadians who
are outside today patriotic peace-loving
canadians who are called misogynists and
racist by the prime minister
so again i will ask the prime minister
who may i remind this house war black
face on more times than he can remember
apologize to the peace-loving patriotic
canadians who are outside right now just
asking to be heard will he speak to them
and then they all stand up and clap so
just to just to quickly summarize she
said you know he smeared these these
people these peaceful protesters a prime
minister and then you hear someone
actually say blackface prime minister
and then she says a prime minister who's
worn blackface more times than he can
remember
has the nerve to smear and insult these
working class people so when we hear
these stories about how really bad china
is and and how it got to that point
we can see similar things happening here
we're actively resisting up in canada
they've got people obviously with the
freedom convoy the great honking people
are actively resisting in the u.s we're
getting stories now that maybe in the
u.s is going to be some great honking
protest some trucker stuff so i'm i'm
fairly optimistic to be honest i think i
think we're going to resist all this
yeah i'm glad to see you optimistic we
have no place to go well also you're
running for office so i mean there we go
i mean even more optimistic well i hope
so i'm glad i'm glad i can make some
difference i feel it's my calling to do
this when i feel my country is becoming
like china it's like a hell no how about
my three adult children how about my
grandchildren how about all the freedom
lovers
let me ask you though are there in china
are there people who are from america
going over there and being like we we've
got to make sure china stays like china
because it's becoming too much like
america with freedom yeah our businesses
[Laughter]
actually i have i haven't seen that like
the u.s council office staff and
families wanting to leave china now
because they cannot stand there's zero
kobe policy but i mean are there
americans who defected to china who love
communism and want to live under that
speaking in the media being like
america's terrible and china's so good i
don't remember any that's why i think we
need to volunteer so they call me these
professors from this country and social
justice lawyers please will you go to
china
we're gonna love it send them over there
yeah i will pay for it i know you will
you do see though if you turn on um
chinese state media so cgtv they used to
call it cctv9 but they changed it to
cctv you will see westerners on there
american
and british professors in some cases who
are going on that are delivering you
know these essential cct uh ccp talking
points on these things talking about oh
it's so great that china has the
olympics yeah it's so wonderful yeah
they're all being yeah they're making
money you know and you track it down and
they had some like you know maybe
adjunct assistant faculty position
somewhere at some college that nobody's
ever heard of yet when they go to china
they're they're featured as this great
american scholar and here they are and
they are paid to push the company line
and we see this again and again and
again this is why
there is an actual elite merger going on
i mean it isn't even just you know there
was that harvard professor who was um
charles lieber who was finally convicted
he hasn't been sentenced yet but you're
seeing some of this stuff with mit the
scientists at gsk who just got arrested
in philadelphia area who are digging
into of course monoclonal antibodies so
this has been going on more and more and
more and yeah there are people who are
doing it but i don't necessarily know if
they're doing it because they believe it
or just being paid well remember the
confucius institute
how naive we were allowed a chinese
government-funded organization called
confucius institute going to our
colleges set up schools in in middle
school high school to teach children our
children about china and glorify china
and
until they wake up it's like 15 years
later they have infiltrated china can
and like united states canada australia
and now you know what happened in
australia and you got hong kong
protesters right to support hong kong
student movement you got the pro-beijing
people and they were fighting you in eu
and they're fighting in australia two
sides are equal it's like
wow communists are in the western
democracy countries everywhere yeah i
should i should just uh point out with
people like lebron james and mark cuban
and even i think elon musk has made some
positive statements about china as well
maybe they're not just in china you know
going on chinese shows and being like
man you know china's so great and when i
see china becoming more like america i
said we have to stop this we need to
make you know but you have lebron james
you have the nba you have american
companies so it's probably worse so elon
and i think i talked about this before
the last time i was on the show he's got
his twitter and on his twitter he'll be
very you know he almost like libertarian
sounding sometimes right on his twitter
account but elon's also got a wechat
account and wechat and he's got a weibo
account so these are this is chinese
social media and he'll go on there and
he's congratulating the ccp on their 100
year anniversary he's congratulating the
chinese government he's opening his new
tesla
showroom where in xinjiang in the actual
province where the weakers are all being
locked up so you know just something to
show that you know he's clearly got a
different message depending which
audience he's talking to
so so so what ends up happening here in
the united states uh are we are we gonna
see uh active resistance
when when we look over at quebec we have
the trucker protest with the freedom
convoy they're pulling back the vax tax
they're worried about social cohesion
but uh there are some countries in
europe that are doubling down like you
know austria's and they've made the
vaccine compulsory i'm wondering
you know what happens here in the united
states because it's
i just don't see at this point how you
could possibly unite the left and the
right the barrier is solidified they
believe completely different things they
will they will not listen to a word you
say it is it is just
two sides with no with no middle ground
i can i can united at least the people
of new hampshire and the country because
i
um i'm the like inconvenient minority
who knows the strengths exception in the
united states but also knows the
division of society that
caused by government and the media
colluding together to divide people yeah
but yeah i agree but i mean look they
say the the the funny point that was
brought up to us in a super chat was
that the left claims black people can't
be racist but candace owens is racist it
i just feel like there is no
compromising and would be going it's
perfectly fine yeah i know roseanne barr
gets fired from her show for making an
off-color joke whoopi goldberg outright
makes crazy statements with the
holocaust and they're like well you know
yes all we have to do is speak to people
who are confused independent in the
middle
that this kind of division is very
dangerous to our country and
our children because it's a typical
communist tactic like by mao he separate
people into oppressor versus oppressed
sounds familiar today
and the five black classes under
oppressor and five red classes on the
oppressed then going through struggle
sessions and the gay people hate each
other and they control all the media
remember xinhua news agency was a
private media company when the ccp
funded 1920s
later they become the largest propaganda
machine in the world so i don't buy into
like oh i want to speak to eggs they're
just private company are you sure 100
private no government pressure no
government investment and no pcs like no
look at the shanghai news agency so we
have to kind of i want to trade people
with respect i know both sides sometimes
i think we need to tone down a little
bit to say i respect your
opinions even though i don't agree with
you but i'm waiting to listen to you
have conversation with you well it's
interesting because even these large
social media companies in the
organizations we refer to as big tech
many of them have investment from
inquitel which is actually united states
government run venture capital firm what
i would like to ask you lily is
have you had any success at reaching
americans who identified as communists
or socialists as opposed to the people
in the center i gave you example i have
been going to colleges for past four
years to speak to students when i went
to west virginia right here right the
university
one bernie sanders supporter come to
listen to my story my talk he stayed for
a long time two weeks later he went back
to turning point usa organizer and
hostess to say please tell lily
she changed my mind amazing wow and now
he joined the turning point usa wow
government sucks so they realized
i didn't ask her to say that
you know
i don't i don't think the republican
party is the answer i think it's got to
be the people getting out and voting in
the primaries voting locally
i say it like whatever it is if you
don't know what it is i remember seeing
you know in chicago's like vote for comp
troller and i'm like i don't know what
that is and but you've got to know what
it is you've got to vote for these
people because what happens is even your
school board ends up getting taken over
by you know marxists communists far
leftists
and they've
we've seen this in west virginia
people from the dc area that are ultra
woke far left move out there
specifically to get elected to school
boards so they can start indoctrinating
kids in conservative areas in moderate
areas in apolitical areas that's what
they want to do they want to spread that
message so you've got to pay attention
to who these people are you got to know
who you're voting for you got to vote
local you got to vote for your state rep
your state senator you got to vote in
the primaries because you're you're
running in the primary and if people
want someone like you to win they got to
go out in the primaries to vote yes
otherwise you get neocon establishment
republicans yes and you cannot be
afraid you cannot be afraid to call
white supremacists racist you have to
reject that those people who call you
there they just don't know the history
if they're young or if they do do that
it's marxist communist tactic don't be
afraid of them corny we have to
counter-strike to say you are marxist
did you did you see that uh
ted liu tweeted at ron desantis or
whatever and he's like it's not hard
just to condemn nazis ron i saw that now
as just like
at this point
i don't think there is any unaffiliated
person who is sitting there going like
wow ron desantis wouldn't condemn nazis
he must be raised no no i'm sorry at
this point everyone's either like i know
he's not but i'm going to call him that
anyway or they support him and they say
we know you're just lying yeah
there's where is the where's the person
confused about this i think what's going
on though and i think a lot of people
are missing this is that in all the talk
about ron desantis 2024 will iran won't
he run is he going to go against trump
et cetera et cetera a lot of what's been
missing in that conversation is that ron
desantis is up for re-election this year
in florida and so people are missing the
fact that you are going to get psyopped
by the media and by the left like you've
never seen before in florida now
remember ron only won by like one point
right the last time around in 2018 now
he he wasn't as much of a household name
back then as he is now his approval
ratings are much much higher and so
obviously with the mood of the country
he should do quite well but they are
going to throw the absolute gauntlet at
ron de santa so they're going to go this
is just the start this is just the start
of it they find some crazy group on the
side of the road
you are going to see a complete unleash
on ron desantis and that's going to be
the test run for 2024 maybe maybe but
the one thing stopping ron desantis from
a potential 2024 run is that he is the
governor of florida and a lot of people
want him to stay there because he's more
effective than he would be as president
if they come at him and they actually
end up winning florida then desantis
could run in 2024.
maybe that's good for republicans and
populists or or maybe you're right and
maybe what they want to do is they want
they want to take the governorship from
him so that he says okay well now i'm
free to run in 2024 and create a rift
between him and the trump and trump and
the support and the base and maybe
that's you know chaos strategy they will
do anything they can to split up the
populist movement you're seeing them
already do this you're seeing people who
are just spread you're gonna see like
ron by the way
what's the big right to the main the
main argument for ron desantis and i i
don't have like a dog in this fight i'm
not arguing one way or the other but the
main idea is they say well trump has
baggage and ron doesn't and and and ron
is effective and you know people get
turned off when they hear about trump
but with ron he doesn't have that stuff
the point is to give him the baggage now
they want to bloody him up and dirty him
up and destroy his wikipedia page and do
anything they can to just put as many
marks on this guy before 2020. i i think
we have deeper problems than that that i
don't
i don't know if that's going to matter
as much i'm sure obviously it won't
matter but i hope it doesn't
this this country is so hyper polarized
i don't know how much more we can
withstand
you you can go on look at project
veritas i mean james o'keefe is getting
more and more popular among regular
people i went to uh a little farm nearby
in fact we have a little alpaca behind
lily sitting right here that we we we
put up every so often and it looks just
like retracto i thought it was
retractable it is not it just looks like
it and we were out i was at this little
farm
um just a little farm not super
political people and we were just
talking about regular stuff and they
were fairly moderate and then i
mentioned i think we had just had like
james o'keefe on the show this was a few
months ago and then peop
there's a guy in the store and the woman
they're both like we love james o'keefe
and i was like really and they were like
yes they were like you know we're sick
of the manipulation the lies he does
great work
when i when i i heard that
and we're in like a moderate area it's
like decently blue and and we're like
we're not far from dc so it's fairly
mixed politically but like with all of
the smears they've thrown at him with
his wikipedia page being completely
fictitious nonsensical op-eds saying
project veritas is
far right racist conspiracy whatever
the the the narrative control is gone do
you see what they're doing now on
wikipedia there's actually an argument
right now on wikipedia apparently
there's a page called the um the
massacres of communism and they want to
delete it there's actually an argument
about deleting that page because they're
trying and they're trying to say this
stuff about oh well this this was
unintentional this was just what do they
say in china the famine years the three
years of famine
disaster three years of natural natural
disasters right natural disasters my
point is just it's ineffective
the all the smears they've thrown on
them and still regular people down the
street are big fans of his they they
didn't know who i was they didn't watch
the show they didn't listen to podcasts
but they were familiar with with project
veritas and they loved it i mean look at
the epstein expose that veritas did with
amy rorbach or whatever her name is
robert the biggest story they've ever
done they they get a leaked video of abc
basically saying they had witness
testimony about epstein that there was
that was that was shut down and that's
project veritas doing this
they're not only putting out partisan
information but i use james o'keefe as
an example
that you know when you mention ron
desantis and his wikipedia page and
trying to smear him i'm like i don't
know if it matters anymore i think i
think well it's not just the wikipedia
though and that's not that's part of it
but it's the idea is it's the steady
drum beat and that's gonna you know
first it's the nazis on the side of the
road what happens when there's they
still haven't caught the pipe bomber
from january
what happens when there's more stuff
like that that goes on in i'm telling
you they're gonna throw
so the regime is gonna do anything they
can to take out someone they view but
it's like a person in quicksand
thrashing violently and sinking faster
for doing it you look at what they said
we we covered this the other day talking
about the great honking the toronto sun
was like the trucker protest that are a
bunch of far-right racist nazi
flag-waving people who stole food from
the homeless
and we're just like
columnist that one crazy columnist guy
who was wrong they were like trudeau
said it well like these people just got
in a truck one morning and you're like
you know we're gonna mess with homeless
people today that's our whole cause like
to hear the media characterize them
that's what you'd think it was like you
know hey i'm gonna go be racist with my
fellow truckers like they have no other
motivation but besides trying to be
horrible
minority they call this this this
massive convoy which is now spreading
all these other cities which may be
spreading to the us
i'm just saying i feel like we are
winning and by we it's it's such a
massive and eclectic political group i
mean you've got post-liberal i guess
they call it people who used to be your
traditional liberal not finding
themselves politically homeless or more
aligned with conservatives simply
because they agree on fundamental human
rights you've got libertarians all of a
sudden agreeing with conservatives on a
bunch of issues and it's because the
establishment and the left are so insane
that all these other groups have
basically been like hey can we can we
band together because they've lost their
minds right the time for talk and
time to discuss sometimes just becomes
so hard to find now peacefully i really
prefer we use our constitutional
republic system to choose your truly
represented representative in dc so we
don't have to use our second amendment
of course that's something you cannot
compromise that's our last resort to
fight for our freedom but the same time
every year you have local time election
for school board for others council
meetings seated seats and every two
years you have congressional elections
people just have to
get out of their comfort zone to take
action so if you just keep your head
down i can't guarantee you it's not
going to be over they will continue to
push the companies will
come to test your limits and will take
your freedom away i i
you know when it comes to second
amendment stuff i i don't think i have
the same opinion as a lot of people who
think you know
you know one day you'll need to stand up
for your rights and it's like yeah
but hold on
yes
but this trucker convoy is just a bunch
of people driving their trucks and look
how much they've accomplished and are
accomplishing peaceful protests work
this time that's right in fact uh i've
said it we're not in that era anymore
where standing in a building gains you
political power you know was it with
january 6 it's like what do you think it
is 1700s you stand in the building like
aha we have the building it's ours now
and i don't know what that's going to do
in a digital era but if tomorrow
every single person in new york city
said there is no vaccine mandate then
there wouldn't be one and you know the
you know the new mayor or whatever
politicians can say no no but what we
said and everyone would still like shut
up yeah then there would be none so if
it's not even necessarily about
non-violent civil disobedience or
protest it's about the will of the
people and what they're truly willing to
do non-compliance i mean look at it this
way
speed limit
can't go more than five miles over the
speed limit that's a ticket literally
everyone does
so therefore it's effectively
unenforceable in in in many ways you
might get singled out but depending on
where your jurisdiction is you typically
you're going to be like you're on i was
like four miles over the limit he's
gonna get in my courtroom you know what
i mean so cultural enforcement is the
main is the main issue we need to strive
for and that's why when i look at the
failures of the attempts at smearing
when i look at the ratings collapse of
cnn when i look at the massive
popularity of shows like joe rogan i'm
like we win the message we win
everything this is also all the marbles
this is also why the
trucker uprising
is such an inflection point right now
because you're also it's also relevatory
in a sense because they are actually
taking action that is threatening to the
regime
they are quite literally holding up the
backbone of our society and they are
preventing the supply chain from being
continued in certain areas and in key
areas but
you're noticing though and i've i can
look around
there's lots of people who run around
calling themselves populist leaders you
see as a populist right populist left
calling them conservatives
who aren't supporting the truckers or
who are running around this is by the
way why aaron o'toole who's the leader
of the conservative party in canada
right now just as an example he's
certainly not the only one they're
actually saying talking about
taking him taking away the head of the
party from him because he's just not
doing much to support the truckers and i
think this is absolutely revelatory
situation where
this is a litmus test actually right now
that if you are not actively supporting
the truckers then what are you doing
right really what what else are you
doing other than saying i need to
support these guys because they are
taking action that's being effective in
real time it's peaceful it's fun they
turned it into a rave in ottawa right
they're not yeah okay maybe there's like
one or two nut jobs who show up where
you know the guy's got a mask on
carrying a confederate flag you know
who's he threw him out right they threw
him out so how many people are actually
going to be showing the most powerful
video that came out today was rebel
media when they showed the mounties the
royal canadian mounted police walking
away they were given the enforcement
rule to go in and start arresting people
and they stood down they can't do it
you know uh i remember doing occupy wall
street you've got how many how many
millions of people in manhattan on the
isla on the island i think it's like two
million
and then uh or or somewhere around there
and then the entirety of new york city
the five boroughs is i think what like
seven or nine million or some
ridiculously large number
and i was telling you know how many how
many nypd cops are there thirty thousand
forty thousand
there are not enough cops to actually
stop a seriously large populist uprising
like during the mayday protests there
was something like a hundred thous this
is back directed by there's like a
hundred thousand people in 2012 marching
down broadway and if all of them decided
to just break social norms and go full
antifa city's gone
there's no way they'd have to call the
national guard and they probably
wouldn't even be able to get enough
national guarding you get to a point
where you have 50 000 truckers
what do you do you're going to send in
some mounties start arresting them one
by one you don't have the resources to
stretch the 50 miles to actually do that
they can't do anything well did we do we
even talk about the the tow truck
companies yet no no well that tim too
well let's look yeah yeah yeah well do
you have do you have the story i don't
know if you want to pull it up no i
don't know where to find it i just
wanted to say too here that this is uh
the fact that they can't enforce it is
another reason why it's so important to
them to set the narrative they want you
to be opposed to this group they want to
turn the entire public against them
because they know there's no way they're
going to be able to enforce their will
well i want to say something that lots
of people
because they live in fair they bought
into the rhetoric's government and the
media they feel like oh government is
good for public
health yes and for society and broader
common good but that's exactly same as
the company sold us in china it's for
public good you don't have a gun rights
because without the ccp the china will
be totally collapsed
and we're not capable of democracy
either like taiwan people because
without ccp
there's no stability it's there are two
rules of propaganda number one party is
always right always right number two all
the medias all they press repeat same
lies every day by lots of people
you become the truth
so i have to thank you tim you and your
all those alternative comedians and jack
you you are bringing truth to people and
and you trust people to decide and i'm
just trying to wake up people to say
stay away from the media go to
alternative media and truth should give
you the power and to set you free
and that way you can understand what is
government now oh government is not just
a requirement it's a force if they
mandate something you don't follow
you'll get fined if you don't pay your
fine you're going to go to locked up
you're gonna lose your job you're gonna
stay home look what happened to
australia right it's just people have to
understand government represents force
against the regular citizens you can
choose to get a vaccine but if you force
somebody get a vaccine
what what is a freedom about if you
cannot even control what this goes
inside your body as medicine that's
fundamental human rights so all those
leftists support human rights should
understand that government is full let
people decide amen so we have this story
it's from western standard now i have to
say i'm not familiar with what western
standard is i've never read them before
and uh uh part of me wants to say well i
don't know if i can trust this news out
but i gotta be honest when i read the
mainstream media i often know that i
can't trust them so
i'll just say this take it with a grain
of salt for what it is this is what
they're reporting they're reporting that
alberta towing companies are rejecting
requests to supply trucks to the rcmp
quote a lot of these smaller companies
don't want to ruin their reputation in
the communities they serve so they don't
want to get involved i mean
that sounds
that sounds
i mean completely
correct and reasonable i mean imagine
you have a small business
you're a tow truck driver you know
everyone loves the truckers and the
police are like go toe you're gonna be
like no
and if you if you read down in the story
it does say that they actually were
calling the tow truck companies directly
to get quotes from them and that they do
have a few listed you know they said
they talked to some people out of the
calgary area and they've got they've got
names and specifics involved in this so
you know that it seems like pretty good
reporting
um
but it's the same idea that look these
guys are in the calgary area these tow
truck companies and they're saying look
we work with the trucking industry on a
regular basis right you're asking us
essentially to go after our own
customers and our friends and our
partners and our b2b contracts that
we've got and that we would obviously
relationships that we don't want art to
have you know to injure and so
we're not going to take this work and we
just don't want to get involved and you
know the mounties are saying come and
get them so then the mounties are going
to turn around and say well wait a
minute you know what do we do like how
do we get rid of all the trucks even if
they go in certainly they can arrest all
the truckers but that wouldn't move
when you're just not here to move the
trucks right you need the the trucker is
right they've got you know the keys and
i don't even know if the mounties you
know do they have cdls can they drive
those drugs do they have the infra it's
that's actually one of the beautiful
things about the trucker protest right
because you know the logistics are is
what they always say is that
uh uh amateurs talk strategy
professionals talk logistics what think
about it right actually think through
this what if you wanted to shut down
these protests logistically how would
you do it
well that's the beauty of these protests
right you can't you actually can't i
mean i was mentioning this the other day
if the protest is literally everyone
says let's go drive downtown no one's
broken any laws
so sure you've got these big rigs that
are pulling into the city and they're
honking their horns
but if the cop walks up to one of these
rigs say ottawa who's honking the horn
or who's on the highway and they say hey
everyone's got to get out of here you
got to move back buddy i'm not here with
the convoy i'm just driving my truck
what are you going to do about it right
your intent is within your brain you
illegally parked your truck yeah i mean
if you're if you if if they all go to
downtown ottawa and they're all blo and
the city's gridlocked the cops can walk
up to you and say move your car like i
want to
be like no more protesting i'm not
protesting i'm just driving my car we're
stuck also the fact that
truckers have this kind of power when
they protested and power that we'd never
considered i mean so we all understand
that they deliver the food to us they're
incredibly important but everything
you're mentioning about the fact that
you couldn't tell them tim what you're
saying about the fact that the police
could never really enforce a suppression
of their protest because you can't
determine intention in that way it just
goes to show that for all the leverage
that they've had the fact that this is
the first time that they're actually
speaking out and having a protest of
this sort really speaks a to their
collective character in b the fact that
they're probably right about this this
isn't a group of people that's
constantly fretting and trying to get
their way this is a serious issue and
they're saying can we please be taken
seriously as valued members of society
and be allowed to determine what is put
into our own bodies i'll tell you this
this is
the rate so
it's a brilliant protest trigger convoy
they're going about it very very smart
uh
tactfully
there's a lot truckers could do to
completely
shut down a country yes and they're not
doing it because that would probably
piss off too many regular people
imagine if on all of the two lane
highways across the united states two
truckers just went 20 miles under the
speed limit and drove side by side yep
grit just jamming up every interstate
across the country and it would only
take a couple hundred trucks to do it
now imagine if you had fifty thousand
truckers across the us who all decided
just the two of us right now in this
spot are gonna are gonna cause a major
traffic jam tim you're gonna accuse you
of inciting violence now in the media
for saying that some trucker's going to
do this i'm kidding no
trucker truckers do this in protest i'm
saying if they wanted to go to a larger
scale they could and they're choosing
not to they're just in a big convoy
showing everybody that they they support
a cause they oppose the mandates yeah
imagine if they actually tried to
disrupt trade
imagine how insane first of all
imagine if they just said i'm not
driving today so nobody brings food if
they did a general strike imagine if
they were like i'll drive but we're
gonna drive real slow there's so much
they could do they're choosing not to do
well and think about too and trudeau
even has i found his tweet the other day
you know he had hashtag thank a trucker
the other day because so think about it
all of the blue city leftists that have
been supporting lockdown policies for
all of this time because they've got
their sinicures they're making their
money right they're all still getting
paid for sitting at home doing nothing
they're doing ubereats they're getting
you know they're getting their netflix
the reason that they have supplies their
entire lifestyle was upheld that entire
time because simply because to your
point truckers never went off the job
truckers never stopped working truckers
are literally essential workers right
you know there's this whole you know i i
don't even know who it was that came in
and said oh the news media is a certain
reality i don't think the news media is
essential working no you're not even
right no truckers yes absolutely an
essential job
hold on uh no and it's those so those
same but down my point journalists it's
those same exact people who are
attacking the very people
that allowed you to be able to live
through those lockdowns when you were
living lives of luxury for an entire
year i got to push back journalists are
essential workers
but we don't have any is the problem we
have like
a handful in this country yeah so when
you know cnn is like we're essential
workers i'm like shut your mouth like
not you know when you have the small
handful of actual reporters people like
matt tybee for instance and what rebel
news is doing there on the ground that's
essential reporting but cnn's panels
about donald trump during covet please
you know there's truckers in canada
actually remind me remember a lot long
ago we had the southwest the pilots
caught in sick yeah cancer results
that's right it's theirs in a peaceful
way to also protest but this is
interesting i actually talked to a pilot
to understand because the media said
there's no sick out it's fake news
so i i talked upon the phone and he said
there is no sick out there is no protest
it's worse than that what had happened
was
the mandates had stressed the workforce
to the point where they were just
individually saying i'm gonna call and
sick today wow so it wasn't like anyone
organized anything you know when i was
being told by this guy was like listen
the idea that there's an organized
protest means there's a lot of people
who are just following the leader but
this is actually grassroots when they
announced the vaccine mandates a lot of
employees just said okay i'm gonna use
up what sick time i have left and i'm
done
so all of these people calling and
saying disrupting everything well the
media was correct it wasn't a mass
protest it was worse the system was
collapsing yeah it could be individual
just to start to resist and stress out
it's like i just don't feel like going
to work anymore you know and that's the
beauty of it i said you know that's that
we have so many people like that in this
country once they had enough of the kobe
two years shut down rise of
tierney and the people it's like this is
not the american we know about and now
what's going on also in school shut down
schools parents cannot go to work
learning stuff that they don't approve
online and tell parents you could be
potentially domestic terrorists people
are fed up people are made up yeah one
thing that's actually going i think to
be an unintended consequence of this is
that
truckers all of a sudden just found out
how important they are that's what i'm
saying the next level so you're gonna
see by the way a lot of the you know for
if there's collective bargaining that
goes on they're gonna be getting paid
and you're gonna see i do think you're
gonna see a lot of people now looking
out at this and saying you know what
that doesn't actually look like a bad
life you know right you don't need you
you you don't need to go to college you
don't need to get massively in debt you
go get your cdl which you can study for
it you can get it you learn the basic
mechanics of being able to operate a big
rig you go out there and it basically is
if you are willing to spend that much
time on the road but hey you get to
listen to long-form podcasts like tim
cast irl while you're driving and others
while you're driving the truck and
you know you you get to see tons of
parts of the country and you get to make
bank we actually have a friend
who immigrated here on the green card
lottery from eastern europe um came to
the u.s literally i picked him up at
dulles airport him and his wife with
they had two suitcases with them but he
was a commercial truck driver back home
learned enough english to be able to
pass the test within five years
he owns two of his own trucks now owns a
home he's been driving his wife's
english is better than his so she's a
dispatcher and he's been to like all 50
states already yeah well with except
well 49 not hawaii yet so
one thing i was
sort of touching on and wanted to get
into a little bit here is the fact that
for as unbelievably powerful and
important truckers are as a collective
group the fact that we have not heard as
much from them as a force as you tend to
hear from other unions and worker
organizations and groups of people in
this country and i don't know that it's
so much the case that truckers just
realized how important they are now i
think they've known but this is one of
the professions where people still
genuinely care about the contribution
they're making to society rather than
just what they're taking home in terms
of money and also i have to say this
another reason why i do genuinely
believe that they care about what
they're doing they care about what
they're providing and they tend to be
more down-to-earth people is because
this is one of the few professions where
you can support a family that does not
require a college education right and
that means these people are not going
off to these institutions to be
brainwashed with all these ridiculous
ideas and coming out as communists and
look at how the establishment left
smears and insults people who don't have
college degrees yeah this this
condescension this elitism
it's uh smarmy it's gross
and it shows the distain for working
class people exactly there's a there's a
comic that's uh funny it's from stone
toss and i love how the left really
really despises stone toss i don't know
much about him other than there's comics
on the internet and one's good and it's
a leftist being like you know the
workers of the world you you know
workers of the world unite and then it's
a right-wing guy and he's wearing a
cross and he's like all right i'm in and
then the leftist is like
no nothing
it's like it's like we support the work
this this is by the way where you get
um marxist leninism comes out of marxism
and then eventually maoism came out of
that because
um the problem that lenin realized in
trotsky early on was that the workers
just weren't revolting against the
government the way that that marx had
intended for them to do with historic
progression and so they re they re you
know the realization that lenin had was
that marx missed something that you need
this revolutionary vanguard that can
lead them through and i'm actually
reading about halfway done um
uh pyota rangel's always with honor now
he was the leader of the white army in
the russian civil war so you know my
background's more in china chinese civil
war cultural revolution but i said you
know what you know russia is actually
where it happened first and so mystery
grove publishing is doing their book you
know they're bringing it's actually his
autobiography his memoirs that have come
forward and it's amazing number one
because he's a great writer it's just
he's really good at writing um you know
giving a narrative but also he explained
that the bolsheviks of their time
it was exactly the same as what we're
living through now so exactly the same
yeah i want to add something people
might not know
um workers rule sounds great the
proletarian rule but if you grew up in
china like i did when you actually a
workers family you have least amount of
food rationing coupons you live in a
primitive conditions and you always work
look dangan i have
been literally working parents i
grew up in that neighborhood everybody
looked down on me because i i'm a
daughter of in literary workers parents
or starving and then later you know once
companies take over the workers cannot
unionize there's no independent unions
in china because you have to have a
communist party committee
to supervise your workers organizations
so you lose your actually the workers
rights so people cannot buy into that
yeah you go but i want to ask lily
question there's a viral video on reddit
right now because on reddit a whole
bunch of leftist extremists forums are
becoming increasingly popular like late
stage capitalism anti-work work reform
they're overtly communist but there's a
video going viral of a guy explaining
how capitalism is modern slavery
and it's one of the
most
i don't know if this guy he's got he's
got a podcast where he talks about
capitalism being evil i don't know if
he's just an evil guy who's lying to
seize power you know he wants to
convince people to support a cult
ideology or if he's just really dumb but
he said
he's like in capitalism
you will never be paid what you're worth
that's a myth you have to be paid less
than you produce for the employer who is
your feudal lord who takes the excess of
your labor and steals it and i'm just
like and you can choose to quit and then
you can choose to start your own
business and then you can become a lord
whereas in feudalism you couldn't
whereas in these other countries with
slavery you couldn't just leave that
position but this is right this is the
essential link between communism and
capitalism that nobody likes to discuss
because both are two sides of the same
coin of materialism and i know where you
know that
absolutely is that if you are basing
your entire system around material goods
and material wealth then you're going to
find one system or another that supports
it or supports the reallocation of it in
in terms of socialism whereas if you
look at capitalism as a tool right so
okay we will we like free enterprise
right we want free enterprise but that
doesn't mean that the economy the needs
of the economy the needs of the gdp
should come at the you know should be
given priority over the needs of
families or over the needs of people
that actually live in these communities
that's why our country has been hollowed
out the way it's been because of this
merger between us and the ccp that's
been going on for 30 years that's why
the jobs have been shipped overseas and
there was someone on a podcast recently
who was saying that it's actually a good
thing that american jobs were all
shipped over to china and all of the
wealth was shipped over to china and
that's ridiculous because what that did
was it empowered the ccp it funded the
growth of the chinese military through
american fdi that's where this is going
we have underwritten it and lily you and
i were talking earlier about how the
city of shanghai that you know the area
across the river pudong has gone in 30
years from being um you know farmland
into one of the most uh built up
financial capitals of the world well
guess what to the american people
you paid for that you all paid for that
yeah i want to pull up the story um it's
actually a series of tweets the story is
actually
an opinion piece from jack bosovic from
newsweek this year's olympics will
double as xi jinping's coronation this
was a fantastic probably the best piece
that's ever been written in newsbeat
social i think
i do like how you you referenced your
own article with wow you saw that no it
was pretty good it was an okay piece
so i i tweeted out the yeah the excerpts
from the article but i took my name i
took i cut it so that you couldn't see
my name and i throw wow
so check us out check us out uh this is
a guy i believe he's from the southern
poverty law center right yes he said
very highly credible
newsweek i wanna hear what he said
newsweek just published an op-ed by
neo-nazi collaborator and stop the steel
liar jack posobik this guy is beneath
oan and not oan and now just extremely
embarrassing maddie hassan then says
congrats to newsweek opinion editors
josh hammer and bungar sargon
for their ongoing struggle to mainstream
and normalize the conspiracists far
right in this country now what i just
want to mention we were talking about
earlier is how they keep trying to do
this this smear of calling someone a
nazi far right or whatever and i just
like here we are sitting with jack
posobik who's a nice guy who talks about
politics and not once have i heard him
espouse anything in any way supportive
of any of these groups i actually talked
about and it's funny to hear media
assange say that because mediasan was a
presenter for al jazeera for many many
years and has spoken out again he made
his bones in in reporting and later at
huffington post speaking out against
islamophobia well many if you had
actually taken the time to read the
words that i wrote in newsweek there's
actually a whole section in there about
the concentration camps of uyghur
muslims in xinjiang
that
may be something where we could actually
agree on so there's two points here
there was around i wanted to bring this
up i mean for one you're here so we can
talk about it hi calling you
these names like a neo nazi collaborator
it's just i i don't believe any regular
person any any you know you you you go
knock on a random door and you show it
to them they're gonna go oh shut up like
i just don't believe these people
anymore like you you go to a local house
of a guy who's not in politics and he's
gonna rate that and be like i don't
believe it you look at maddie hassan
who's now pushing the same narrative but
like you said he didn't even read what
you wrote it's the same thing with the
joe rogan story everyone i love the meme
going around where it's like joe rogan
spreading misinformation oh really what
did he say
nobody knows see that's how dangerous it
is it's the silence dissident voices
mouse culture revolution you cannot even
talk to your family about anything
because what if your family member
report to the local raid guards then
they could go to struggle sessions so i
had to self-censor when i started to ask
questions i only asked myself inside of
my own head i could not say well wait
tim do me a favor you're on mediason's
page right there do you see over to the
right where it has mediason's bio right
now does it say where mediason currently
works yeah it works for nbc so he works
for nbc and he has a
uh a show also on nbc's peacock which is
their streaming service now uh i did a
little digging on this um really really
deep digging it took me you know
seconds of time to search this up nbc
signed an eight billion dollar contract
with the international olympic committee
to be their exclusive host for the
olympics all the way through 2032 and
then the exclusive streaming service of
the olympics is and it's so strange
peacock tv the exact same place from
eddie hassan has his streaming service
so it's so strange to me that
such a coincidence that they would send
this guy out
absolutely billion reasons but to come
out and be it's like the
they used to actually you know have
front groups for this sort of thing now
they're just doing it in the open like i
just like try harder guys come on i just
saw this story and like i mentioned the
the the trying to smear you then not
even reading the article the joe rogan
spreads lies but we don't actually
listen to a show anyway and i'm just
like i don't think they're
i think i think they've lost i think
they've outright lost well this is what
the establishment malice
yeah so so that's the other thing i want
to bring up michael malus responded to
maddie hassan saying impotence signaling
is much funnier than virtue signaling
they've lost monopoly control over the
mic and don't know what to do except
sneer virtue signal of course being like
look at me so virtuous i condemn that
too but now they're just going like we
can't do anything about this so we're
losers people are listening to joe rogan
and they're not and
jack besovic is getting written up in
newsweek what do we do well and and and
just to to mike i you know i appreciate
it why would they call me them sitting
next to jack
no exactly you're a collaborator you're
not a collaborator
we talked about the other day
we're all posting collaborators no no
look we we talked about yesterday
there's a tweet that's going viral where
a guy says in germany we have a saying
if there's 11 if if there's 11 people if
there's a neo-nazis in a table and 10
people at the table talking to him you
have 11 nazis and that is a psychotic
world view but it proves to the left
politics can only flow in one direction
if you take an antifa guy sit him at a
table and you take jack pasoba and
simmet the same table and they're
talking the left will look at it and say
two far-right individuals even though
the one guy's clearly got an antifa flag
and wearing a mask and everything they
don't care we have a picture of
you know that you follow us that's what
they want to do they want to shut down
any kind of discussions conversations by
name well lily yeah let me ask you a
question when chairman mao
launched the uh
his anti-writist campaign what was every
person so who spoke out if you spoke out
against the great leap forward and you
said hey there's millions of people who
are dying of famine in the countryside
what were you labeled
well
you will lose your job you will get
locked up that's why the people don't
understand when you say ccp dictatorship
means
all the leaders in china are not elected
by people they are appointed by the
upper nine communist party officials so
they actually want to cover it up so
when people die of starvation during the
great leap forward in the 50s excellent
50 million people died but they don't
want to report that to the central
government because it can local
government officials can lose their jobs
they're trying to cover up same thing
with kobe same thing with the stars it's
same thing with flooding so it's very
dangerous here's one thing on team i
want to tell you because of your good
work and our discussion somebody texts
me they just donate it and they live in
new hampshire oh cool
we're getting messages from people
saying they're donating to you oh great
thank you very much you got really angry
about the gun rights thing and mentioned
having the ar15 everybody was cheering
very very happy so you would be right so
they would so officially and they would
and they would conduct the struggle
sessions and it would be around your
neck you would be labeled a right wing
extremist for saying there were people
dying and can of famine and committing
even in some cases cannibalism in the
countryside just so they could survive
remember this this raider guard like the
raid guard do yes struck sessions did
you say this twenty-five point salute
yeah
twenty twenty i've seen college students
in america march down the street doing
the red salute yep yes well so lily
speaking of college students and these
types of people one question i want to
ask you lily is prior to the maoist
revolution did you know people who were
leftists or communists or was it just a
very well organized small minority that
ended up infiltrating and taking over
were were the people calling for this or
how did this happen
well of course i had no idea i was born
like a into the mouse culture i was two
years old to 12 years old i was totally
indoctrinated i had no idea we were just
told that the taiwan people are starving
to that and lots of people are living in
hell we need to go labor them and we
need to be grateful for the party for my
mom i would just because i still had a
little bit brain right i said but we're
starving now it's like how could be
worse off they were right i mean to us
but it doesn't matter you self-censor
you don't ask questions i never
challenged anything in my life until i
was 12 years old when mouth died it's
like
oh my god died because the weight
chanted every day long never chill my
mouth 10 000 years double ten thousand
years
until he died it's like oh you know who
lied to me that's what i was wondering i
was whispering to myself and i decided
to go to college study law so i can
change china maybe search for truth but
by the time i went to law school and
then they told me no no no no it's not
for justice law is a tool used by the
party to govern its masses soviet union
model
i got lost again really i had lots of
very depressive totally so lost moments
in my life until i came to this country
you were telling us last time you hear
that you had to like lie to try and get
out of the country and pretend that you
would you know you lied and claimed you
would come back yeah everything has to
be pc because you need the permission of
the party to quit your job otherwise you
pay money back you'll need permission to
go get a passport so i
that's why i call myself a stray rat
because i had to survive if i want to
come to the united states for my freedom
i had to say what if is pc oh i'm gonna
get a college master degree here in the
us to serve my country better on my own
time on my own time i will come back to
serve my country okay sign agreement the
agreement is i must promise to go back
to china after my master's degree okay
all two consequences will kick you out
of the party
because
you know i was forced to join party in
order to teach in law school as a
faculty member you must have the party
membership otherwise they don't trust
you where your loyalty you got to be
loyal to the party so i don't care about
that okay you can't kick me out i was on
probation status anyway first year i
hate it because i just could not believe
anymore then next one is very hard they
kick you
a personnel file to your hometown which
is chandusuchwan because if you live
work in shanghai you must have your
personal file to go with your job but if
you don't go back on time they kick your
file back to chengdu so that means i i
there's no hope i can go back to
shanghai and live there as a legal
resident have a benefit because they
have ties to your benefits
so i guess chairman square that the
political asylum status kind of you know
gave to every chinese student so i was
okay later to go back to china but but i
had to cancel my trip 2019 because i was
threatened how dare you speak bad about
your motherland in the united states two
students
so i said i'm teaching the truth no
you're a traitor
so i was threatened when was the last
time you were home
2015. i miss my home
my family my extended relative one
brother three uncles one aunt and
cousins
i met some people who traveled through
north korea and they told me that
if there is like a small town or village
and they have a cow and the cow dies
they can't touch it they have to call
the local military officer who's you
know appointed to come and take the cow
to be distributed evenly among the
country for everybody
if you take it to eat because you're
starving they they put you in the work
camps or they outright kill you and
execute your family
so it's just
you know you don't know every day every
minute you could be breaking the law
that's how bad look when you talk about
oppressive reaching
it's just people have no rights or
you're treated like some animals without
human dignity everything you say
everything you do you are criminal i
don't hate to see americans becoming
like that way there's so many laws you
don't know which day you would be
breaking the laws you mean like if
somebody was holding the door open for
you at the u.s capitol and you walked
inside unbeknownst because you thought
that you were just at a protest and now
suddenly you're putting a gulag i mean
the police opened the door for the
police not just somebody and he said on
camera i don't agree with it but i
respect your right to protest waving you
in
and now those people are yep
yeah it's ridiculous yeah that's where
we're at
well maybe trump will get reelected and
pardon a bunch of people or something
but i don't think they're getting that
long of presence trump
should really
do something right now for the people
that are behind bars right and if he
could do something set up a legal fund
set up a way just just he can't tweet
anymore but you he could post it through
his um you know through his press
release do something for the people
now show people that you're still in the
fight if you want people to know that
you're serious do something for the
people because guess what they don't
have the ability they don't have the
luxury of waiting until 2025. they're
behind bars right now well what can they
have every citizen supposed to have they
speed in trial you cannot hold people
this longer uh supposedly no political
prisoners in a free country it's like
why are the people still locked up
without the trials
you know we we need to do something and
question it to say hey we need to
advocate you know they should have a
speedy trial and you should have jury
and then you should you should have all
that means like it's become so political
now so you can get bail out if you're
violent criminals and burn stuff and
looting property somebody will raise 23
million dollars for you to get out you
come out you commit another crime you
kill more people but those people
january 6.
you know they're still in the jail lily
and i think the exact reason for that is
because unfortunately uh most americans
don't value the principles upon which
this nation was founded as much as you
do as a citizen and i think the ones who
do value it are too complacent to
actually do anything about it
so they bought into the media rhetorics
and uh have you i think i think many of
them the thing is i think many people
haven't bought into the media rhetoric
but it happened a while ago they're not
thinking about it it wasn't me it wasn't
my family it wasn't anyone i care about
so i'm just going to forget it just like
just like the people saying nazi germany
by the time they came for me there's
nobody left to defend me
that's how you lose a country so fast
solzhenitsyn wrote about that he said a
lot of the people who when they were
brought away by the guards um they would
be told they would say oh well they were
asked to come they said well i'll just
go down because this is a big mistake
and i know i didn't yeah i'll go
downtown i'll go downstairs explain
things and they never came home but the
you know we were talking about uh
fundraising a second ago and i don't
know if you guys have seen the story
that andrew kerr uh leads to the
washington examiner now uh has been
reporting about blm and the donations of
blm and the fact that they walked out of
2020 with 60 million dollars in the bank
and we remember that in the wake of the
george floyd video going viral there
were companies just throwing literally
throwing money at blm but andrew kerr is
actually doing the work now and i think
he even went to their registered address
in los angeles and is trying to figure
out hey so who's in charge of the money
right who's in charge of like who are
the actual fiduciary uh stakeholders
here who is responsible for the 60
million dollars he can't because we saw
people uh patrice cullers and others
have resigned from blm so who's actually
in charge of the money he can't find
anyone who's in charge of this didn't he
say the address wasn't even legit like
he went there there was nothing there
right and the guy said they've never
been here and then they said well hold
on but we we appointed two people who to
serve as the new you know the new
runners the new chairman of blm but then
those he went and interviewed those
people and they said oh yeah they
appointed us but we never accepted wow
so we never accepted the appointment so
that's fraud that's 60 million dollars
of fraud right there and so if that's
all true and he's by the way he's saying
that i think um
i think the state ag is actually opening
up an investigation into this because
that that's straight up non-profit fraud
if that's what's going on
all right we got to go to super chats so
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already
smash the honk button honk the like
button one like equals one honk and with
your support we will get many many homes
go to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a members only segment coming
up for all of you guys the uncensored
non-family-friendly version of the show
at 11 p.m around then over at
timcast.com don't forget to share the
show with your friends subscribe let's
read some of these super chats
all right
little bear says would you kindly make
trucker hat merch with the honking on it
or something else cool i wonder if luke
is listening to this and has already
started making that as soon as he's on
the super chat uh yeah we could we we
recently made a new shirt it says uh it
says join the cult
it says join the city urban liberal
types and then spell down it says
and then it's uh it's it's a our version
of the meme where the guys are like you
know soy mouthing and pointing behind
them and the city's on fire and being
destroyed by godzilla and aliens oh my
gosh make america honk again i don't
know he got those hats let's make speech
free again what other players make
america honk again yeah
i love somebody is already making that
hat right now and selling it they're
gonna make a million i saw a lot of
people have been doing like the um like
the canadian goose right you know yeah
yeah yeah that's like yeah i saw that i
saw the flag of it and said please leave
me alone
yes
i saw someone someone tweeted um uh the
reason canadians are so nice is because
they store all of their hate in their
geese
[Laughter]
all right let's grab some more so um i i
think this bear's repeating just someone
asked about it the moen says lily tang
is a congressional candidate what is
your position on the second amendment
types of firearms that people can have
access to and self-defense now i know we
did talk about it already but would you
be in favor of americans owning rocket
launchers
rocket lunches yeah
you know that i saw that some people do
have that do they i don't know i'm in
favor of americans only rocket launchers
well you know you know whatever
government soldiers have
don't you think that uh they can have
everything
i personally do yeah i think the
constitution says the right to keep and
bear arms and
although it's probably fair to say the
founding fathers didn't expect scud
missiles or whatever well did not have
their technology back then yeah yeah
they did have cannons and then and they
did have a machine
and they had multi-barrel multi-barrel
guns that could simulate full auto so my
my issue is if a private citizen could
own a you know a frigate with a massive
you know cannon volley system or
whatever with great shot and all that
stuff and they and they they uh
commissioned privateers
why wouldn't an american citizen be
allowed to have their own you know sam
site here's my stand that uh um second
amendment in the past you know of course
before we had all the modern technology
all the modern you know machines you
know um arms that only talk about guns
but what if someday the guns no longer
very effective and useful to protect
your life poverty and liberty what do
you do
we have the involved too
that's a that's a really good point yes
arms what does arms yeah what are they
what right what if we're using
lightsabers and blasters are we gonna is
the government going to be like uh
the second amendment doesn't cover
blasters and lightsabers well i i think
that we have a constitutional right to
use whatever we can to defend our family
and the liberty and property and we were
involved with technology and just like
the government you know troops will so
what's wrong with that otherwise when i
effective defend ourselves anymore if
guns are not defective you know i think
american citizens should be allowed to
have nuclear arms
nuclear weapons well calm down tim i
don't know if i go that far
why not nukes you actually want
citizen's own noose uh does the
constitution say i thought you were
trolling does the constitution say the
people the right of the people to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed
unless of course it's a nuclear bomb
it's a nuclear arm it's true
one of the biggest ones my point i just
think my point is more so
if you want to re uh restrict the rights
of american citizens to have the same
weapons uh that you know that
governments have you need to amend the
constitution well the other thing that i
love that the constitution doesn't say
is by the way special asterix that we
found i guess nicholas cage could find
it at the bottom of the bar of the bill
of rights the original bill of rights
i found the original bill of rights
oh my gosh
bert says
that during a time of pandemic all of
this stuff is just it's just suspended
it's like they had pandemics of course
they did they were they're smallpox way
worse
way way worse during the time of the
revolution and they didn't write
anything about that i love the i think
it's what patrick henry meme where he's
like give me liberty or give me death oh
unless of course there is a pandemic in
there
in which case no follow the guidance of
the medical
medical
medical look look i'm sure a lot of
people you know their immediate reaction
is like whoa regular citizens shouldn't
have nukes
and and and corrupt crony politicians
should no they shouldn't either well
right so the point is
at what point did we just become a
civilization a society that says only
the ultimate you know ultra powered
authoritarians are allowed to wield the
most powerful weapons the point of the
second amendment was that to secure a
free state the people need to bear arms
it didn't say accept cannons and accept
large warships no no i said arms and
private citizens had warships yes they
did i mean nuclear power generators are
run by private companies like
westinghouse is a private company but
does anybody does any private company
like this could you imagine if bazel
started building nuclear bombs i know
they're like well if the truckers don't
want to comply that's what we're going
to do like you think he won't in space i
got to be honest i'm pretty sure the
nuclear weapons are actually built by
private companies
did one of the founders fathers say
something like this like
if people are afraid of government is
tyranny but if a government is free to
people it's liberty that's true actually
let me let me just clarify that past
point i mean raytheon halliburton
lockheed boeing these are private
companies but are they really right i
mean and this this kind of gets into
what you were saying earlier about
quinoa in in china that essentially they
are a government-run enterprise i mean i
don't think you can realistically look
at a company like boeing and say that
they're not a state-related enterprise
yeah all right let's read some more
super chats we got rekramorsen says a
few friendly facts of canada alberta is
where usa gets a lot of your resources
that's why they're protesting there for
your information also canada only has 70
000 military 100 000 police and two
million gun owners
so are you saying that they're
we're actually at a point now where
there may be more truckers protesting
than there are yeah wow that's amazing
man
all right justin
bookman says hello tim and company as a
truck driver the fact that trudeau
cowers in fear of facing the
consequences that he started george
strait said it best this country turns
on 18 wheels thank god we can depend uh
we can depend brothers of the highway
children of the wind breaker breaker
it's crazy man could you imagine what
these like these hipster city urban
liberal types would be doing if the
trucker stopped delivering avocados to
him well this is what they always talk
about when when people say if you know
if we go into
um a a post-apocalyptic scenario that
the cities won't be able to feed
themselves well of course they won't be
able to feed themselves because they're
fed through trucks right now right if
you are eating it came from a farm if
you are eating in a city it came on a
truck right so the minute that this goes
away that the cities
where do they get their food
oh yeah let's read some more super jets
i was preoccupied for a moment
all right let's see kevin bill says the
star trek parody episode of black mirror
is the best one love you guys and wish
you all the best hong kong good luck
lily the star trek parody episode of
black mirror it's the one this is all
the most like no that was i think it was
like season four star trek parody
episode i think it's where that uh i
think he like takes their dna and traps
them in a star trek simulation oh yeah
yeah which one
oh that's right the episode of black
mirror that is parroting star uh star
trek that yeah yeah yeah any and he's
trapped in his own little verse
yeah yeah
all right let's see anthony baron says
earlier tim you talked about that people
think all asians are chinese when
referring to the whoopi story made me
think of king of the hill where khan
moves next door are you chinese or
japanese so whoopi goldberg you know
we'll talk about that one remembers only
for sure uh yeah but when she said that
she said the holocaust wasn't about race
uh sheamus brought this up he was like
that's like saying the rape of nan king
was not about race at all because all
you know they're all asian yeah exactly
because she said it was white people
killing white people and so my thought
was well that's like saying the racism
is killing asians that's a ridiculously
offensive thing one of the most racist
things you could have said but it also
shows you all the same to me that's like
that would be a career ender for anyone
who wasn't on the left american identity
politics is essentially reductionist
it's totally reductionist because if you
go to any of these if you go to europe
or you go to asia obviously they view it
as separate races obviously
oh yeah well also i mean this idea of
like race and dividing people into black
and white is is much more modern
probably i don't know between 15 and
1700s but historically people have
always divided themselves up based on
their language culture and borders so
ethnicity has been a much more
meaningful distinction for virtually all
of history which and you notice that
whoopi is is kind she tries to which you
want to own colbert she tried to say
that and but it just didn't come out at
all
all right dubious prime says lily tang
is great and i give her the best of luck
on her campaign some people you should
look into is a youtube group called adv
china they do great work on the beauty
and downfalls of china i do i do watch
them i know those guys are great yeah
actually
they were the motorcycle riders in china
for years and years and they all warning
people oh you gotta leave china now you
gotta leave
evodio tovar says lily tang is my spirit
animal
oh thank you what kind of spirit i'm
dragon lady i'm my zodiac dragon even
though today's the tiger year start
all right let's see we got here in the
super chats
zabruci says they're not scared of guns
they're scared of survivors of communism
opposing them with guns i love it
wow what a
great comment
yeah
i just watched um
just a superman red sun
it's the uh it's a comic but they made a
movie of it where it's a reimagining of
superman where
his ship crash lands in the soviet union
and then he ends up becoming a communist
it's really interesting it is they the
way they the way they view it he he
basically witnesses the holodomor and
then goes and confronts stalin and
stalin tells him
in this system some people have to die
so then superman goes very wise words
and then executes stalin on the spot
that they have like becomes the dictator
who takes it over
well stalin meant man of steel
superman is the man of steel right is
that the whole thing but then isn't it
also that um
so that batman they they they work
batman into the holodomier as well he's
a little kid so he's a little kid in
ukraine and that's like it's kind of a
crazy thing for a fictional show to do
oh it's like it's like you're a cartoon
character
one of the worst genocides in human
history that being said though who else
is actually talking about that stuff i i
thought that's true when when when
stalin explained popular culture
motivation
and superman is like yup and then kills
him and takes over i'm like
that's and on to be fair like captain
america fights the nazis and stuff right
so it's but this is a reimagining of
superman's story as if he was raised in
the soviet union it's actually really
interesting because
it's it came out the the graphic novel i
believe came out in the 90s yeah it's
like older it's an older story it
definitely could not be written today if
you're working for dc no way you know dc
really likes to be extremely brutal like
everything is very adult and very
graphic and just totally brutal like i
was watching titans
yeah i don't want to spoil anything but
let's just say like it's gory to put it
mildly you look at the marvel stuff and
it's very family-friendly but then you
know i watch the justice league stuff
and
we just saw the new um the new scream
actually and it's extremely gory
fantastic movie though really it is
anti-woke um it's an excellent story
they brought back the original writer as
the executive producer obviously wes
craven is around anymore but
it feels like a 90s movie it's
definitely anti-woke um it is gory just
the same way the original one was gory
maybe a little bit more gory than the
original scream but um it's even
something where because like tanya had
never seen the scream movies before my
wife
um and because she's born in soviet
union and uh she watched this one and
they explained enough of the original
that like you don't need to have watched
any of your uh regular ones before you
see this all right let's read this when
we got we got danabus he says the media
today would not report on tiananmen
square it's appalling now i think it's
worse than that i think if tiananmen
square happened today they would report
on it oh yeah but imagine right-wing
domestic terrorists
a group of domestic terrorists far right
yeah we're trying to an insurrection
somebody in hong kong protest somebody
yeah somebody would show up with like
one flag and they would say oh look at
this guy with the flag of the dynasty
they go look this chinese man has a
confederate flag
[Music]
chinese students were holding american
flag and the sciences we want the second
amendment right here yeah
like i don't know if they show that or
not but i had the picture good for them
yes all right ridiculous envy of the
world a very very important super chat
ridiculous says hong kong
i love it thank you
yes
that wasn't ridiculous at all free hong
kong oh my god
yeah that's a good one yeah there we go
all right hong kong if our merch crew is
listening there you go there's another
shirt idea all right lost valley says i
finally unsubscribed from philip
defranco after 12 years because i
couldn't stand the leftist elitist
talking points he spouts every day
what happened to these people phil
defranco's the guy who hosted gary
johnson in like 2012 or whatever on
youtube
now it's you know
it's just all generic narrative
establishment i never followed him too
closely because i don't just mean
hillary franco
i don't know
just
but just people in general where's neil
young who's mr i'm a working man
standing up for the trucker he's
canadian actually i i heard that he was
like deeply homophobic is that true well
there was a comment that rolling stone
apparently reported back in the 80s when
aids was coming out where
and they reported that neil young said
something that i probably can't even
represent a little bit while we're on
this week we can talk about it brutally
humble like it was like we'll talk about
it in the next hour but it is bad i've
heard some bad stuff but if this quote
is real i was like man this is like
that's a brutal thing yeah like it was
which and i'll give new york the benefit
of the doubt because this is rolling
stone and i do not believe anything that
is just printed in mainstream media i
just don't believe it and it's it's a
shocking comment because it's like you
could you you could disparage with
people but he went far be i you was
i don't know man i guess people change
it's true that's true man dude they grow
some people grow apart too after they've
been married for 30 years so i guess
people change
true yeah
all right
let's read some more super chats
we got a let's see we got here
jerry mckinty
watch dr jay peterson's canadian
constitutional crisis brian peckford the
last living premier who wrote the
canadian charter of rights in 1982 is
suing the government for violating every
canadian's rights
very interesting
erica lee says i'm not ready to lose
desantis as governor right now we need
him where he is the political climate in
the state is way too tenuous at the
moment yeah can i make a quick point
about this because we were talking about
uh
potential ambitions for you know
becoming president of the united states
and there's a really important question
to ask here where is he more valuable i
think if you were to ask the question is
it better to have like a really good
solid president like him or 50 really
good solid governors i think anyone
would say 50 good solid governors and
it's a question of like all right well
what if it's 25 what if it's 10. i think
ultimately florida needs him really
badly right now and i think he's a
fantastic example for other people who
want to be effective and popular as
political leaders to look to and emulate
in their own state the desantis model
clearly is the winning model exactly
all right david says f that here's 50
for lily's big ball energy and i don't
mean big ball in the tick tock way
yeah a lot of people have been chatting
they've been donating to your website
what's your website again
it's a little tom williams.com then then
you can click on it for congress i have
youtube video there two minutes
announcement video why i'm running and
keep the american dream alive the spot
says if she doesn't win i don't know who
should more american than most americans
agreed isn't that crazy could you
imagine like like foreign i'll give you
the pitch right now for for further
leave for congress
imagine her giving speeches like this
from the floor of the house of
representatives and then every single
news they and by the way like the stuff
they do to like lauren bobert and mtg
and others they will go after you like
crazy they'll find some tweet you liked
or something and they will go nuts
because as you said before you represent
a huge problem for their agenda they'll
say she talked to you jack i'll say [ __ ]
to me right
i have a very thick skin because for
freedom liberty which is my north star
there's nothing else
that uh you know i'm not
willing to do i'm waiting to die for
this country so whatever they take on me
don't want to have a conversation with
me i always would smile and have a
conversation but if they just call me
bad names i think i only make them look
like nazis this is what you know what i
was saying about uh a lot of these
people who are coming up from the
southern border
they're these i have infinitely more
respect for the people trying to enter
the country illegally through the
southern border because they love this
country more than many of the people who
live here granted
they'd be better off entering legally i
don't like the i don't i don't respect
the fact that they would disrespect the
country by breaking its border but
there's something still within those
people where they're like they look at
the american flag and they dream of
being there because of opportunity but i
don't understand this country is so
racist and backwards and sexy why would
anyone want to come to systemic research
that's what i'm saying imagine if you
know when we we we open our doors to
immigration and through a legal process
we'd be bringing in all the people who
really really want to be here and love
this place but the problem is the people
who are here who hate this place are
making it worse making it more like the
communist you know are you suggesting a
trade that's what i'm saying haven't you
oh yeah the
but uh
you know the weird thing is exchanges
these people don't want to leave
programs they hate america but they
won't leave have have you ever seen
somebody from america want to like
escape and cut the barbed wire to go to
another side
there are a lot of americans who sneak
into canada for real so they're usually
like low-income younger people and they
try to get into canada thinking they'll
get free healthcare or something
usually doesn't work out and canada has
an actual immigration system so it
doesn't work out it's actually i think
it will so uh i i think luke actually
went up to the border where people were
crossing over there's no
like real defense for canada i mean
here's the thing though right right now
you need some passports
yeah you do yeah but i don't i don't
think that's the way the immigrants
healthy protests no i know yeah yeah no
that's my problem but that's and that
that is exactly that's the essential
issue is you can have
immigration or you can have a welfare
state but you can't have both
you can't have both you cannot have open
borders and a welfare so legal
immigration is a way
and i'm a pro-immigration but i'm
pro-legal immigration because american
people have some kind of say you know
what kind of people they want to come
here and they want to security too but
here's something also crazy about legal
immigration let's say example my brother
i petitioned for him to come to this
country after i become citizen he waited
13 years
if i was a mexican he would wait for 19
years that's why you give people
incentive to come from southern border
when it's wide open because who has
lifetime to wait for the legal you know
immigration opportunity and it's a
vicious cycle because part of the reason
it takes so long for people like you who
want to go through the system and the
legal process to get here part of the
reason it takes you so long is because
of all the people skipping in line and
coming into the country without
permission well that's not fair at all
because you know that i think we need to
really have a good conversation about
immigration here but right now without
secure border
it's a chaotic and it's national
security threat and you give incentive
to the and human traffickers and drug
dealers could be even the terrorists
sleeping from southern borders
any conversation on on immigration
the opening bid has to be the borders
need to be
you need to have control of the borders
first period then we can have a
conversation about what's due afterwards
amen let's read some more super chats we
got diane prokop says would be so
grateful for a shout out of my
children's book on friendship lunar new
year and the endangered chinese river
dolphin it's titled the baji michael
malus knows about the dolphins
does he that's true no the dolphin it is
um
in some cases has been eaten a lot the
river dolphins in china
you can barely find them anymore
wow
all right not bob saget says tim have
you heard of portland andy he has been
on top of the convoy the entire time
some of the best coverage you can find
shout out to all the hot dog warriors
out there with the ones and
does it say ohs
fjb
all right i've i've been hearing a lot
about portland andy i'm not familiar but
uh no i don't know i don't think so he's
from business he's from portland
he's not that's not portland indy is not
andy no i think portland is a different
streamer okay
okay yeah cool
right on
all right let's see what we got
lacy ferguson says i'm starting to feel
like we've been cast in the remake of
red dawn and it's being directed by
quentin tarantino
maybe
i don't know though
all right let's see we got will you get
amanda milius who's the daughter of the
original
director oh there you go
the care of bear says true north rebel
spencer fernando western standard news
for canadians
uh maxine bernier uh bermier bernier is
it burn is our only hope love from
calgary
and then someone said marcus said tim
will for president never
if like all the people rose up one day
and they were like no we really do mean
it tim be president i'd be like give me
one minute i just gotta i gotta go get a
pack of smokes and then you're right
they were gone there were actually like
instances in church history of a group
of people rising up and deciding that
like one person should be their bishop
and he's like i don't want to i don't
wanna guess what that's why you have to
yeah exactly like
but it's also like it sounds noble like
the people are like yes you're our
leader it could also be kind of like i'm
not doing it you do it yeah yeah that's
right
cardinal shift too one specific example
i can't remember the exact one but yeah
yeah there's there's one recently in in
um in the 1980s in poland where they
wanted this um you know this guy was
sort of mediating between the the
solidarity union and the communists and
he's like he's like look and they and
and one of the leaders had actually met
with john paul ii and said hey my local
bishop should be a cardinal and and john
paul ii just starts laughing
the one i'm thinking of and i wish i
could remember the name but the guy was
not even a priest at the time and
they're like we need him to be our
bishop and they do ordained if he made
it based
all right we got a couple here sandra
nadeau says dear we truckers have always
known the importance of what we do this
hasn't made us realize that it's made
you realize it
yeah but but the fact that the truckers
show restraint and not shutting
everything down whenever they don't get
their way is like i think james just
said it's indicative of their of their
their moral character yeah my my point
was ask for more truckers seize the
moment take vienna when you set out to
take vienna take vienna right
go for broke right now this is literally
your moment so any kind of bargaining or
contractual agreements you have right
now you it's the dead of winter supply
chains are already creaking just go for
broke do it
all right tbagan elite says oilfield
trucker here those canadian boys are
awesome and deserve respect i listen to
the show daily and i get to make great
money no college debt and i make more
than most of my friends that went to
college i love it and then
he posted a bunch of duck emojis
yeah
this is this is part of why i made the
point
oh my goodness um
that was you that was actually me yeah
that was me
you can't blame that on me i know all
right um the part of part of why uh i
love it though and part of why i
mentioned the fact that truckers like
don't generally go to college is because
i just i trust them so much more as a
group i know i really do like if you're
gonna talk about one group of people
that have strong political power within
their profession it's like yeah truckers
well this is why biden and every
politician that shuts down fracking it's
a direct assault on truckers because i
remember this coming from pennsylvania
you know talking to people from that
northern tier or the western part where
the marsala shale was found that it i
remember sitting with a trucker once and
he was telling me that like he said i
can make as much as i do now
hauling in one day in my local just just
area where i can take my kids to school
in the morning and now i can be home
with them in the evening and i can make
as much as i do now thanks to fracking
then i used that you know i used to be
on the road for a week doing this and so
that's why fracking is actually such a
huge issue for those parts of
pennsylvania for ohio it would be huge
in new york because new york state has
the marcellus shale underneath it but no
governor is allowing the development of
this that's why the trucking industry
and then you get the secondary and
tertiary benefits of that through it the
same deal if we were able to open up
alaska more i was just up at the
northern shelf there etc etc right you
get actual economic benefit i don't want
to invade afghanistan or the middle east
i want to invade the united states yeah
invade alaska get the oil from the
united states elliott says i am a proud
poso collaborator
boom let's do it
so bill hughes actually has a really
good point about whoopi goldberg he says
so whoopi there wasn't genocide in
rwanda
uh oh yeah oh oh
so let's answer that i think i think we
should talk about the goldberg thing for
the members segment because it's going
to get real spicy talking about world
war ii
she is she oh really oh
my gosh so like was her career there
there was she'll be back out
throwing it down right now she'll be
back i don't think i don't think
roseanne shouldn't have lost her job and
and whoopi goldberg shouldn't lose her
job people are allowed to have dumb
opinions suspended yeah she might be
back yeah i know i know i'm just so the
view is abc well this as a viewer of the
view this really breaks my heart
[Applause]
have you guys ever seen the family guy
joke about the view
they're all just clucking and they're
balking and then all of a sudden one of
the women goes and stands up and there's
an egg and then the camera zooms in on
the egg while they're all blocking i
just thought it was a really well done
joke they would never do that joke again
though yeah it's just the women the view
going back
and then they're surprised they laid an
egg and they're all bucking louder
about it
all right everybody
smash that honk button one like equals
one honk support the great honking
protest um subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends go to
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only uncensored segment up
around 11 or so p.m you're not going to
want to miss it so sign up you can
follow the show at timcast irl on
instagram and everywhere else you can
follow me basically everywhere at
timcast lily do you want to shout
anything out
well that i want to tell people how they
can follow me and contact me right
besides my website and i also have a
facebook page
lily for congress used to be lily for
liberty so i already built up 22 000
followers now it's changing to lily for
congress so please go there and follow
me and i might do live i'll give you
update and please donate as i said this
is grassroots campaign our freedom it's
not free we need everybody donate help
me to put me what's your website so
people can support you
littletongreniums.com
ladytongwilliams.com i would really
appreciate i'm on twitter i got 10 000
people or something and i'm on instagram
and youtube i'm everywhere i'm trying to
do my best to save you know america i
love i have no place to go so i don't
know about you guys where would you go
if we lose this country i don't want to
go anywhere i want to stay here yeah
i've been to a lot of countries and
america is the best by far so we need to
stay here fight we have to have faith in
our system in america people
so let's you like it yes right on
yeah jackpot you guys know where to
follow me uh
twitter getter facebook rumble etc uh
the podcast is human event daily we are
the cliff notes of your day's news and
tomorrow morning if you want to catch me
i am actually going to be guest hosting
war room pandemic for the great uh steve
bannon so i'll be running the show out
of washington dc
seamus coughlin freedom tunes if you
want to check that out i release
political cartoons every thursday
sometimes uh on tuesday or other days of
the week as well if you want to check
that one also i just want to lily we
have a lot of great guests on here but
honestly you are you are really a great
american and i i love the spirit that
you have and how badly you want to fight
for this country so i just want to plug
lily for congress again to everybody
watching thank you thank you now now i
don't feel alone anymore like i did in
china i have all of you that's great
yeah i think it would be amazing to see
we have you on the floor unbelievable
imagine if every member of congress
loved america as much as you do can you
imagine just a couple of them you know
just
a caucus i don't even need all of them
to just get like a couple of them there
is a there is a russian immigrant from
former soviet union is a congresswoman
right now
and she once compared fbi what they're
doing to say i are you becoming kind of
like a kgb that was a great speech yes
yes cnn has it up by the way whoopi
goldberg 9 49 p.m has been suspended
from this moment
we got to talk about it we got it we got
some f's in the chat folks no no fs and
chats don't care about that i was going
to say uh rand paul really does care
about uh the us because he was just at a
restaurant that they tried to shut down
for the vaccine passport thing um and i
did want to say lily thank you for
stopping by again i'm very excited for
your run i am lydia i produced a little
podcast live stream called kim task irl
and you guys can follow me on twitter at
sarah patrick's also on mines she's the
best she brought me here twice also i i
will say too i was not i meant no
disrespect to rand paul or the few
people in there who actually do care
there are some before before i get
accused of you know mr whatever it is a
two-week
suspension well i hope she thinks about
let's see
let's let's get to the nitty-gritty of
everything that's going down over at
timcast.com in the members segment so
check it out sign up we'll see you
around 11 p.m thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you